[Applause]
this week we've talked a lot about
abortion and those conversations are
really important but one thing that can
get lost in them is how our society
takes care of kids once they are born
because sometimes this system that's
supposed to care for our most vulnerable
children actually hurts them more i'll
explain in a segment called how did we
get here
[Music]
tonight we're going to talk about foster
care so just so we're all on the same
page
foster care is when for any number of
reasons a kid is cared for by the state
instead of by their parents foster care
is not a secret system to care for the
safety and security of broadway legend
sutton foster
now
foster care is important we need a child
welfare system to take kids out of
dangerous and abusive homes and keep
them safe but it's also important to
point out that the system is not the
same for everyone for example in los
angeles county black kids account for
only 7 percent of the population but are
24
of child welfare services population
which is insane black people haven't
been this over represented since tv
shows figured out they could cast us as
therapists
500 black therapists on tv
three in real life
now
those numbers mean there are a lot of
black kids who are being taken from
their families and removing black people
from their homes obviously isn't new to
america it's the foundation of slavery
and also what happens early on in most
seasons of the bachelor girl
you were never going to get to stay in
that house
but
in real life our country has a long
history of taking kids from their
families and it's not just black kids
all the way back to the late 1800s
hundreds of thousands of native
americans and indigenous children were
taken from their homes so that they
could be quote unquote civilized by
white people now just a reminder in the
1800s white people were forcing women to
wear these
also in the 1800s a white guy and i
swear i'm not making this up patented
this actual trap with a loaded gun
that's real so honestly civilized white
people had so many bad ideas it's
amazing there are any left
now
the trend of taking away native kids to
live with white people continued for
decades in studies from 1969 and 1974
the association on american indian
affairs found that 25 to 35 percent of
all native children had been separated
from their families and put into the
foster care system or adopted and 90
were placed in non-indian homes and
that's just horrifying
uprooting a kid and placing them with
someone of a totally different
background should be a last resort
unless that kid is a scrappy redheaded
orphan
she'll do fine and she'll make you
realize you're in love with your
secretary
now part of you might be saying hey
maybe these native kids were actually
sent to places that were safer
i wish that were true unfortunately the
reality is many of them were sent to
schools where they were treated so
poorly that thousands of them died from
abuse and poor living conditions the
last of those schools didn't close until
the late
1990s which is shocking i thought the
worst thing happening in the 90s was
blues traveler
that [ __ ] was fine for like one or two
songs but this band went on multiple
tours and that is unacceptable
now things have gotten better since then
but even today native children are four
times more likely to be removed from
their families than white children are
from theirs so the question is
why
why are black and native children being
removed from their homes so much more
than white kids well the first reason is
easy it's because they're being
investigated more often according to a
recent study in the american journal of
public health half of black children as
well as half of native american children
experienced a child protective services
investigation at some point in the first
18 years of their lives 18 years of
getting the run around oh run around
i take it back blues traveler is
actually pretty great
but hey maybe the investigations are
necessary after all we don't want a
child staying in an abusive home but
here's the thing the overwhelming
majority of child removals do not even
allege abuse in fact it actually turns
out that most charges against parents
have to do with one thing poverty that's
right people are literally having their
children taken away because they are
poor which is terrible if money made you
a good parent then succession would be a
comedy about four well-adjusted kids
now
foster care agencies have little
incentive to fix things that's at least
partially because america has
started using privatized foster care
that's right and maybe the most
terrifyingly american thing ever our
country has turned taking kids away from
their parents into a business and the
more kids in the system the more that
business profits unsurprisingly it ain't
going well a bipartisan congressional
report found that for-profit foster care
agencies had quote abuse neglect and
system failures at every level which by
the way is also the official slogan for
the catholic church
the good news is that
every everybody went
i see i remember what you're talking
about
the good news is there are some
solutions counties in california and new
york have been trying something called a
blind removal program and no it's not to
remove the blinds from your white
neighbor that she uses to peek through
while she's calling the police
looks like they're having some sort of
cookout and they're using a suspicious
substance called seasoning i'm going to
call 9-1-1
blind removal is actually a program
where caseworkers don't disclose the
race of a family when making decisions
about whether or not to remove the
children and so far it seems to help out
a lot new york's nassau county reported
that five years after removing race from
the deliberations 21
of children in foster care were black
compared with 57 percent before blind
removal which makes it pretty clear that
a whole lot of black kids were being
removed from their homes for no other
reason than the fact that they were
black
the fact is we need to find a way to
protect black and native kids from abuse
while also removing the bias from the
system now that means taking race out of
the equation and also telling our
government to stop the privatization of
foster care
oh and last but not least we need to get
some more black therapists because these
kids are going to need them this has
been how did we get here
[Applause]
[Music]
you